suite sport de 2014 on ne change pas les
bonnes vieilles habitudes c'est parti
pour un nouveau tour de la cus ports du
département en 26 minutes ce week-end
elle encore organisait un concours
qualificatif pour les prochains
championnats de france en salle de tir à
l'arc mais aussi ultime étape de
sélection pour les mondiaux à nîmes
résumé à suivre focus sur le mma dans ce
set vite sport réunissant de nombreuses
disciplines le free fight continue de se
développer arrive à maurepas ou 1000
mètres carrés sont désormais dédiés aux
arts martiaux modernes en football ce
week-end était consacrée aux 32e de
finale de la coupe de france poissy
était le seul club yvelinois amateurs
encore en lice face au breton de
concarneau résumer à suivre évidemment
comme d'habitude en fin d'émission tous
les résultats du week-end mais tout
d'abord on passe à notre page football
et promotion d'honneur
c'est encore la trêve hivernale pour le
championnat de promotion d'honneur et
notamment pour trappe l'étoile sportive
de trappes qui pointe actuellement au
septième rang après on va dire un peu la
première phase aller est évidemment le
président de la best rapper est présent
sur de 7,8 sport mustapha larfaoui
bonsoir à vous merci de nous rejoindre
sur les missions et meilleur rue
évidemment pour cette nouvelle nouvelle
année en tout cas bonsoir
comment vous voyez cette première partie
de saison septième place vous avez
longtemps accroché nanterre qui est
l'actuel leader d'ailleurs je trouve
peut-être de jeter un petit coup d'oeil
au classement comme ça on va remettre
tout cela en contexte vous êtes 7e vous
avez perdu un petit peu de terrain voilà
vous avez 26 points 35 points le leader
nanterre derrière saint leu 31 puis 29
et 28 vous n'êtes pas trop trop loin
encore un du podium à quelques longueurs
à trois longueurs comment vous jugez
cette première partie de saison mais
écoutez je ferai pas de je ferai pas de
pronostics vous souvenez qu'à cette même
place il n'y a pas très longtemps je
faisais pas de pronostics mais j'avais
un voeu pour l'équipe de france de
gagner 3 0 et le voeu est exaucé je
formule le mmm veut pas de pronostic
mais le voeu de d'être au moins sur le
seul podium cette année je vous rappelle
que tu rappes l'an dernier il ya deux
ans par on était dernier à la trêve pour
pour finir premier alors c'est peut-être
un exploit qu'on ne souhaite pas
renouveler j'entends par là en
commençant par la dernière place cela
étant on parle de la 7e place moralité
on était deuxième il ya deux matches
donc ça va très vite parce qu'on fait
que le groupe est très très serré
c'est une poule très homogène et donc
c'est très serré donc en fait c'est en
fonction presque dire c'est très
circonstancié pas très bon on va dire
que c'est pas trés c'est plus
mathématique autres au chan le groupe
avait quand même besoin de recharger les
batteries sur cette fin de mois de
décembre il ya eu une défaite assez
sévères notamment à paris-xiii il y
avait une petite lassitude une petite
fatigue du groupe ou pas
je ne qualifierais pas de pas de fatigue
en l'occurrence mais je crois qu'on a
encore une fois des très concurrentiel
cette poule cette année on a un leader
nanterre qui est très performant et j'ai
vraiment le sentiment qu'on a on a
on en face de nous quelqu'un de très
très très en forme ils vont être
inaccessible cette année ou pas vous
pouvez en voir aller les chercher rien
rien rien là inaccessibles pour les
joueurs ils en ont fait là la preuve à
plein d'un pas beaucoup de reprises mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut craindre que
nanterre soit soit vraiment la
locomotive sera lancé soit lancée à fond
d'autant plus qu'on a chez eux un choix
assez exceptionnel du niveau de niveau
de nationale qui est à la fois joueur
qui est à la fois entraîneur qui fait la
pluie et le beau temps avec son
équipement qui d'entre elle marque les
buts ils passent devant il passe à
l'arrière
alors le football c'est une équipe donc
je me dis qu'à un moment donné l'aller
qui devrait faire la différence voilà
c'est tout le voeu que je formule que
l'équipe fasse la différence 7e est pas
parce qu au début de la saison je me
souviens quand même qu'il y avait des
petites velléités de monter ça fait
longtemps où vous êtes en promotion
d'honneur ça serait ça c'est un câble de
passer montée justement en dhr en
division d'honneur john al ça serait
intéressant pour le club
car depuis longtemps sait jamais deux
ans ça fait ça fait longtemps qu'on
cherche effectivement à marquer
a marqué des victoires et larqué
démonter parce que je pense que c'est
aller à l'image du travail du club
je dis souvent que le résultat m'importe
peu et que c'est surtout la résultante
est un moment donné il faut marquer la
différence donc c'est vrai que c'est la
montée qui détermine
comment dire le le niveau du club mais
en réalité moi je le vois de l'intérieur
vous disais que c'est la trêve oui c'est
la trêve mais ils ont recommencé depuis
le 2 janvier ils sont à l'entraînement
il bosse
alors c'est pour ça que je dis que on
peut sur formuler des voeux surtout en
début d'année de cette année mais en
début de saison on si des objectifs
l'objectif était effectivement d'être
soi leaders sûrs d'être sur le podium au
moins la trêve on l'était jusqu'au
dernier match qui nous ont coûté six
points qui nous mettent à la 7e place
voilà ce que le choc perdu face à
nanterre justement au mois de novembre à
laisser un petit peu de traces et ses
deux défaites derrière qui peuvent être
compréhensibles de cette façon c'est
toujours pareil c'est un match à six
points ils sont premiers on est
deuxièmes c'est un match à six points
tout peut se jouer là tout peut se jouer
et la défaite fait que c'est vrai qu'on
a du mal à on a du mal à s'en remettre
on attend presque la trêve effectivement
comme vous le disiez notre on pressent
que la trêve pour ça et on recharge les
batteries c'est le cas et je sais que
l'équipe ii fonctionne plus trop plutôt
très bien aussi puisque vous êtes dans
le peleton le peloton de tête pardon de
la première division district dans votre
pool vous changez peut-être du coup
votre fusil d'épaulé on va peut-être
essayer de recentrer plus de force et
d'aller chercher cette montée en
première division d'ailleurs on voit le
le classement qui s'affiche voilà vous
êtes troisième là c'est aussi très très
homogène il ya vraiment très simple un
mouchoir de poche en fin de compte 4
points entre vous 3e et marly le roi le
leader 34 points ça va être peut-être la
priorité maintenant à partir de ce mois
de janvier 7,7 équipe réserve notre
priorité c'est tout pareil c'est la
priorité c'est de jouer la priorité
c'est de faire de très très bon match
devant l'arrêt puis de se chercher le
avisé sur l'excellence c'est le cas de
nuon par l'excellent s'emparer de la
béquille et en excellence pour les
téléspectateurs faut savoir que
groupe de trappes la place de trappes
troisième et une place à quatre points
leader donc c'est extrêmement joie pour
le coup alors si c'est jouable pour la
lune c'est jouable pour la ddt pour la 2
un petit un petit coucou également à la
trop puisque nous avons une équipe 3 ans
en 4e division qui est également
deuxième voilà donc on a trois jours
trois coups à jouer on jouera les trois
à fond et encore une fois pour vos
téléspectateurs il faut savoir que la la
1re div et la ph sont juste séparé d'une
équipe l'excellence voilà donc on veut
resserrer également les reins c'est
important d'avoir un club avec des
équipes qui se sert et non pas une
disproportion est noir peut-être plus de
concurrents jusqu'à demain entre les
équipes pour gagner en efficacité tant
que voilà c'est toujours pareil c'est
l'homogénéité d'un club qui est
important c'est l'homogénéité d'une
politique sportive c'est la vision qu'on
peut avoir global d'un club de foot et
alors après sentent peut avoir des sous
et voir des veut voir des pronostics moi
je formule celui ci en début d'année
c'est celui de ne pas te continuer à
travailler toujours plus en plus et
encore parce que c'est la résultante
comme le dit tout à l'heure pas
forcément les résultats
on peut pas évidemment parler de trappes
sans parler de l'actualité un petit peu
brûlante ces derniers jours concernant
nicolas anelka on sait qu'un qu'il a
effectué ses classes du côté du club de
trappes en tant que président de trappes
est ce que ce qu'il a effectuée sur le
terrain en première league ça vous
touche ça vous pèse ça nuit à l'est à
l'image du club de trappes alors sa nuit
pour une raison simple c'est que au
regard du travail effectué et j'entends
que les choses
extrêmement satisfaisants même sur le
plateau ici nous avons le papa d'un
enfant qui disait tout le bien qu'ils
pensaient de l'encadrement et j'en
profite pour remercier lui et tous les
parents qui ont une satisfaction alors
c'est vrai qu'on a encore du travail
mais pour le coup j'ai pas le sentiment
que ça nuise ou que ça fasse pour le
coup
meilleure santé pour rappel pour les
téléspectateurs nicolas anelka a
effectué une quenelle dans le débat
évidemment du comique dieudonné suite à
un but pour célébrer son but en premier
league avec west bromwich albion alors
c'est vrai que ça fait le buzz c'est
vrai que notre ami anelka et est très à
l'aise avec les médias et donc un moment
donné sa part un petit peu de façon
désordonnée à sa part un petit peu j'ai
presque envie de dire de façon débridée
comme il sait l'être sur un terrain
simplement il ya des terrains sur lequel
il faut rester à mon avis un minimum
avec un devoir de réserve je pense que
il en a à mon avis le devoir comme je
peux l'avoir moi ce soir de ne pas
critiquer certaines actions certaine
façon de se comporter voilà on adultes
que nous sommes j'ai presque envie de
dire que c'est un des voix un devoir
d'adultes et de citoyens parce que ça a
des retombées pour le coup sûr tout ce
que l'on gère après de façon néfaste ou
ou pas chacun jugera
moi je pense que le travail effectué 4 1
pas beaucoup plus de pouvoir de force
dans la durée que que tout ce qu'on peut
entendre par ailleurs très bien merci
beaucoup mustapha larfaoui des de passer
sur ce premier set 8 sport de 2014
reprise le 19 janvier à domicile pour
l'équipe première en promotion d'honneur
façon 11e garges-lès-gonesse bravo et
encore merci merci beaucoup mustapha ce
premier week-end de janvier était
consacrée je le disais dans les titres à
la coupe de france de football on va
rester dans le foot poissy dernier club
yvelinois amateurs encore en lice
recevait concarneau les bretons
pensionnaires de cfa mais l'exploit ne
s'est pas produit au stade léo lagrange
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
si le match des tribunes et vite gagnés
par les supporters de concarneau c'est
tout l'opposé sur le terrain du stade
léo lagrange
après un début de match très prudents
les joueurs de poissy en jaune asphyxie
le milieu breton et ils sont même tout
près d'ouvrir le score sur cette
splendide ouverture mais la reprise de
l'attaquant pisciacais passe tout près
de la lucarne bretonne voici prend alors
confiance et les occasions se
multiplient mais à chaque fois nous
cadres il aime pour la cage adverse et
ville
0 0 à la pause
le tournant du match arrive peu après la
mi temps le défenseur central abdoulaye
sangaré est expulsé pour ce tacle en
retard
il n'en fallait pas plus aux joueurs de
concarneau pour prendre l'aventage à la
70e minute l'avant-centre breton soki
n'zinga met fin aux espoirs évinois sur
cette frappe croisée du gauche
concarneau s'impose finalement 1-0 et
verra les seizièmes de finale 24 ans
après de leur côté les yvelinois
pourront regretter longtemps leurs
nombreuses occasions ratées on n'avait
pas fait un grand début de match
peut-être impressionné par l'événement
mais met tout de suite derrière on a on
a comment on s'est bien ressaisi on a
bien joué on allait on a les occasions
on les met pas et
puis après l'expulsion et le tournant du
match en seconde période expulsion très
sévère on jouait pour la qualif on a
perdu donc fait une déception
allez on passe aux sports de combat vous
le savez un an quelques semaines
évidemment officiellement le vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines pas ouvert
cela ouvrir ses portes il n'y aura pas
que du vélo et du cyclisme une académie
de seif qui défense va prendre ses
quartiers le 13 janvier prochain lundi
prochain au sein du nouveau
clairefontaine du cyclisme français et
pour en parler les responsables et
entraîneurs et professeur de self
défense sont présents ce soir sur le
plateau joël savary et samir ou bonsoir
à tous les deux nous soir anthony merci
d'être là alors tout d'abord comment le
projet est innée joël mais en fait c'est
un projet qu'on a mûri l'année dernière
juste pour revenir sur ce que tu ne vous
disiez anthony le vélodrome ouvre la
semaine prochaine le 13 il ya une
amélioration officiel le dragage en fait
cet appel à partir du 1er et 2 février
au public ça sera vraiment complètement
ouvert toutes les activités nous
l'académie où on ouvre le 13 donc c'est
à dire dans deux semaines voilà on va
accueillir le plus le public à partir du
13 et l'idée comment allait aller elle
est venue c'est que avec sami l'année
dernière ont organisé des stages moitié
kick boxing et moitié self défense moi
je suis entraîneur de king boxing et
sami entraîneur de cette défense et la
mayonnaise a pris et beaucoup beaucoup
d'adhérents qui en pratique avec nous
nous ont demandé où est ce qu'on pouvait
pratiquer ce concept en fait c'est une
donc c'est une idée qu'on a mûri et puis
on a parti ce projet un petit peu
partout
on a été dans les différentes mairies et
puis également au vélodrome on a porté
le projet
à vélo police qui est la société
d'exploitation du vélodrome on a été
reçus et puis ça s'est bien passé et
mais je sais qu'on s'était vu justement
à l'occasion de ces stages il y a un an
vous faisiez le week-end dans
différentes salles c'était à bois d'arcy
si je me souviens bien il ya un an vous
me disiez on a du mal à trouver les
salles justement pour nous accueillir là
ça résout quasiment tous les problèmes
je jouais le comme vous voulez ah oui
c'est sûr que là c'est c'est comment une
chance inespérée
et puis on est on est content d'être
d'être accueilli au sein du vélodrome
dans une infrastructure comme celle ci
vous ce qui me plaît c'est peut-être ce
mélange on va peut-être rappeler pour
les téléspectateurs se mélangent kick
boxing et celle défense c'est vraiment
de deux ponts de votre activité voilà la
fête il ya trois disciplines ya le
kickboxing donc la boxe pieds poings il
ya également la self défense donc il est
issu du punch à xi là tu vois là issus
du penjab dilate c'est le pen chaque
c'est un petit peu grave maga mais c'est
ça vient d'indonésie c'est un art
martial et il ya également du travail au
sol donc ce qu'on appelle le grappling
où l'on va un peu se
exactement j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
beaucoup d'activités qui naissent
récemment sur le sel défense ont
l'impression c'est une activité pour
différentes raisons à la mode oui c'est
une activité à la mode dans le sens où
de plus en plus on voit un petit peu du
lait c'est même à comme on apprend dans
le reportage juste avant et en fait il
ya aussi une actualité qui fait qu'il ya
malheureusement de plus en plus
d'agressions donc qui dit agression
c'est aussi comment appréhender une
agression comment savoir réagir comment
se défendre et ça on l'apprendra en
passant par la boxe en passant par de la
self défense par s'empare du mma donc
après il ya la notion sportives ou là
c'est vraiment pour faire de la
compétition se mesurer à d'autres
combattants et ainsi de suite et après
il ya la notion prévention et
appréhension entre guillemets du danger
quel réflexe savoir à quel moment et un
set j'étais justement dans ces courts
que vous donnez quel est le type de
population qui vient assez court c'est
plus des jeunes gens âgés des jeunes
femmes il ya toute la pop toutes les
populations on a des étudiants on a une
population féminine qui grandit de plus
en plus et qui est à la recherche d'un
côté un peu rassurant self défense et
dans cette académie juste pour ne pas
oublier on est trois professeurs et donc
il ya ça me il ya eric également et moi
même eric ça me va en parler
l'idée est venue à la base de joël joël
et moi est en fait eric que moi ça fait
sept ans que que je pratiquais la self
défense est en fait eric gelé connu en
pratiquant puisque lui il était déjà 2e
dan en plein chaque silat et c'est
quelqu'un qui a pratiqué vingtaine de
boxes pieds poings cas fort mais aussi
tout ce qui est agent de sécurité
protection rapprochée et voilà qu'il ya
une approche terrain et pratique qui
s'est vraiment du vécu c'est pas c'est
pas de la télé c'est pas la théorie
c'est vraiment du vécu et qui
qui va pouvoir apporter ça et pour
terminer juste le concept de votre
académie comment ça va se dérouler on va
pouvoir faire soit du self défense ou du
kickboxing il va y avoir des abonnements
mélanger en fait en fait le concept
c'est vraiment avoir un comment une
inscription annuelle qui va permettre
d'apprendre à la fois self défense le
kick boxing le sol et ça de manière
globale pourquoi parce que c'est
important aujourd'hui pour
dire être opérationnels en self défense
si on n'a pas des notions de boxe on
sait pas se déplacer on sait pas ce que
ça fait un complexe et voilà c'est
vraiment avoir la notion de a à z très
bien merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'être passés sur les 7,8 sport et puis
pour plus d'information pour les
téléspectateurs ils peuvent retrouver
tout cela sur
www.cff.ch défense point fr n'hésitez
pas le bandeau qui s'affiche merci
beaucoup merci à très bientôt merci le
mma on va rester dans les sports de
combat les arts martiaux et l'art
martial par excellence réunissant de
nombreuses disciplines le free fight
continue de se développer et arrive à
maurepas ou 1000 m² sont désormais
dédiés aux arts martiaux modernes loin
de sa réputation de combats de rue ce
sport est devenu très technique et
encadrer images de patrick jacques de
dixmude
formé au solo grappling basile note doit
encore travailler la qualité de sa box
pour devenir un combattant complet et
pourtant rien ne le prédestinait au free
fight car avant d'entrer dans l'octogone
il pratiquer le badminton cet éducateur
spécialisé a vite adhéré aux valeurs
dans la cage où se côtoient toutes les
catégories sociales on sait les
exigences que ça chacun entre
combattants et forcément elle afin
d'avoir fait un combat voilà on se prend
dans les bras parce que alors on
respecte l'autre pour tous qui lui même
si on a gagné qu on est perdu ou que
voilà il ya vraiment un respect mutuel
parce qu'on sait la douleur que ça peut
être pour se préparer la france est le
dernier pays européen qui interdit les
compétitions de mma
depuis les années 90 ce sport à la
réputation sulfureuse a beaucoup évolué
l'époque du combat de rue est révolu
le free fight est désormais codifié
encadré et très technique
chaque pratiquement de mma et
multidisciplinaire ça veut dire qu'ils
pratiquent un sport de pieds poings il
fait de la lutte ou du judo a coté et il
fait soit du grappling soit du ju jitsu
brésilien pour développer ses aptitudes
au sol contrairement aux images de
violence régulièrement diffusés des
études américaines ont prouvé que le mma
n'est pas plus traumatiques que d'autres
sports de combat la boxe anglaise qui
jouit d'une image beaucoup plus positive
sur le long terme laissent beaucoup plus
de séquelles que le mma les mecs sont
capables de se mettre entre 500 et 700
coup de poing dans le visage sur un
combat ça engendre des problèmes de
santé après beaucoup plus important que
ce que nous on connait en mma sur 1000
mètres carrés cette salle de sport
presque unique en france propose
également des cours de fitness et
d'ailleurs au boxing l'abonnement annuel
vous coûtera entre 300 et 500 euros
allez on passe à l'essentiel des
résultats du week-end
seuls deux championnat reprenait ce week
end va commencer par le rugby et la
fédérale 3 on suit évidemment plaisir
12e journée sur la poly la pelouse du 6e
l'union des bords de marne les plaisirs
roi dans une rencontre assez fermée se
sont imposés en faisant le minimum
syndical 10,3 ils confortent ainsi leur
seconde place au classement avec quatre
points d'avancé sur le troisième poteau
cobo en basket 13e journée de nationale
3 trappe recevait le cinquième
gennevilliers dans un match aussi assez
fermé les joueurs saint quentinois en
rouge ont une nouvelle fois été très
maladroits les distances les trappistes
s'incline finalement de deux petits
points 60 à 58 il reste englué dans le
bas de tableau à la neuvième place avec
seulement deux points d'avancé sur le
premier relégable les saint quentinois
n'ont plus connu la victoire depuis
trois journées toujours dans cette poule
g de basket en suis lente entre chesnay
versailles qui s'est brillamment imposé
sur le parquet du club athlétique
lexovien 88 à 86 les versaillais remonte
à la huitième place
football féminin ce week-end c'était
aussi coupe de france avec le premier
tour fédéral et c'est déjà fini pour
montigny-le-bretonneux lésigny montaigne
se sont inclinés sur la pelouse de
lambersart profess pensionnaires
pourtant de division d'honneur 1 à 0
encore quelques infos avant de me
quitter tout d'abord du tennis de table
on connaît désormais la composition des
poules des matches par équipes de tennis
de table en nationale une l'entente de
voisins saint-arnoult défiera entre
autres un saint maur joué-lès-tours
quimper ou encore poitiers le maintien
sera évidemment l'objectif des joueuses
de geoffrey nisand et en nationale 3 ans
huile en cours qui sera notamment opposé
dans un derby 100% et blinois à
marly-le-roi encore une petite info du
triathlon on vous font vous faisait
découvrir alan brachet le nouveau
champion du monde scolaire des premiers
championnats du monde de triathlon et
bien les deuxièmes champions shawn les
deuxièmes mondiaux scolaires de
triathlon en mai 2015 seront organisées
à versailles après porto rico le tenant
du titre pourra donc remettre son titre
en jeu sur la pièce d'eau des suisses et
le circuit de satory encore une petite
info c'est du foot us évidemment
elancourt en période de fin d'année et
des fêtes surtout les templiers se sont
offert un beau cadeau en recrutant un
nouveau quarterback il s'agit évidemment
de football américain je le disais le
club élan courtois a fait signer un
américain shaun shelton en provenance du
missouri il pourra prêter main forte
évidemment phénomène miro des templiers
4e du dernier championnat de france
élite confirme la leurs ambitions de
titre en fin de saison afin avant de se
quitter évidemment je vous propose de
jeter un petit dernier coup d'oeil dans
le rétroviseur de l'année 2013 les
meilleures performances les meilleurs
moments les plus beaux moments de sport
et surtout les plus beaux titres c'est
la rétro sport dur et du 7-8 sport un an
après leur visite du chantier les
membres de l'équipe de france sur piste
ont enfin pu découvrir le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
250 mètres de long pour 8 mètres de
large soit 1 de plus qu'ailleurs
l'anneau est unique au monde nul doute
que françois pervis et grégory baugé
iront tutoyer les records à l'extérieur
le team france de bmx bénéficie d'une
arène semi-couverte unique en europe
l'ensemble des installations aux normes
olympiques pourra accueillir des
compétitions nationales et
internationales à commencer par la coupe
de france de bmx en avril prochain
depuis deux saisons il vit une seconde
carrière exceptionnelle après avoir
arrêté le vélo pendant huit ans à 37 ans
yann dujarrier devenu au pays de galles
l'homme le plus rapide d'europe sur le
kilomètre grâce au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le champion belize et un pourra rêver
plus loin plus vite vers le titre
mondial
tanguy de lamotte se souviendra
longtemps de son premier tour du monde à
la voile dixième du vendée globe 2013 le
marin versailles et aura marqué la
course par ces vidéos complètement
décalé au cours de son épopée tanguy
aura été surtout le héros de 15 enfants
souffrant de malformations cardiaques
grâce aux 170 mille euros récoltés sur
internet ces jeunes issus de pays
défavorisés ont pu se faire opérer
le prince de la boxe française a enfin
confirmé toutes ses promesses à 23 ans
le verrier roi ahmed el moussaoui parti
s'entraîner aux états unis a décroché le
titre de champion de france walter face
à franck haroche-horta une première
ceinture décroché à l'image de sa
carrière en toute intelligence
les peut-être l'avenir du triathlon
français à 15 ans le jeune saint
quentinois lan brachet devenu le premier
champion de france de triathlon de
duathlon d'aquathlon mais également
champion du monde scolaire de triathlon
une performance inédite dans l'histoire
du tri s'il vient d'écrire l'une des
plus belles pages de l'histoire de son
sport le livre de sa carrière vient tout
juste de s'ouvrir
treize ans après l'avoir quitté les
féminines de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles retrouve la nationale
une avec 17 victoires et cinq défaites
les joueuses de vinko berdych avait
validé leur billet deux journées avant
la fin du championnat les avec un
effectif quelque peu remaniée et un
nouveau staff à l'intersaison
l'apprentissage du haut niveau amateur
ne se fait pas sans difficultés les
versaillaise reste pour l'instant au but
et à la 11e place de leur poule
c'est la fin de ce cette fuite sport
n'hésitez pas à le commenter un sur
twitter avec le hashtag le cfid sport
tout attaché d'ici là excellente soirée
sur tv fils et je vous souhaite encore
une excellente année 2014